[Music]
it's so optimistic and hopeful
regardless of how bad life can get and I
really needed that message the new
single issue night's first song since
2011 similarly themed today is your day
[Music]
but life's about to get good will be
part of shinai its first full-length
album in nearly 15 years 2002 up that
featured the hit for ever and for always
[Music]
but it was shortly after that album
success that her 15 year marriage ended
with her producer and co-writer Robert
Mutt Lange together they created such
hits as
[Music]
man she laughs a woman that don't
impress name their personal and
professional relationship and and after
mutt had an affair with shinai his best
friend mutt was my partner in ever since
it really hurt in 2011 on her reality
show why not it seems as though Shania
might never return to music I have lost
my ability to express myself and my
deleted thing I've lost it well after
launching a two-year Vegas residency in
2013 Shania is ready for new music again
and ready to prove she can do it on her
own a rose whole album myself so it's a
real statement of independence creative
independence has been something that I
haven't had in a really long time she's
already proven herself she doesn't need
anyone to be Shania Twain and kind of
have that aura of excellence but I think
that it'll be interesting to see what
she has to say this time around really
scary taking that leap so I took it I'll
be done and I feel really good she's
sold millions of albums at this point
she'll still be able to move album units
in 2017
[Music]